[موسيقى]
وزن المراه لا يؤثر على الخصوبه خرافه
فعلا ان كانت المراه ضعيفه لن تحصل اباضه
ولن تحمل والامر سيان ان كانت زائده الوزن
فلن تكون هناك اباضه فعاله وسيكون من
الصعب ممارسه الجنس رفع رجليك في الهواء
والوقوف على راسك يزيد من نسبه الحمل
خرافه ايضا فالحيوان المنوي يصل الى عنق
الرحم فورا ويسبح الى الرحم للبحث عن
البويضه سواء كنت على ظهرك او بطنك او
كانت رجليك الى الاعلى او الاسفل فان ذلك
لا يهم لا تقلقي من امور لا تؤثر عليك
الاطعمه الدسمه جيده للخصوبه خرافه يجب
عليك تناول طعام صحي يوازن بين البروتين
والدهون والكربوهيدرات هناك دهون جيده
واخرى ليست بنفس الفائده بعض من الدهون
المشبعه لن تقتلك لكن الدهون غير المشبعه
هي الامثل تقليل السكر والطعام المصنع هو
المفتاح فذلك سيجعل الجسم يعمل بشكل افضل
يجب ممارسه الجنس يوميا لحصول الحمل خرافه
اخرى لا يجب فعل ذلك يوميا ف ممارسه الجنس
لمره واحده في الوقت الصحيح سيكون الامثل
رغم ان جوده النطفه ستقل ان لم يقذف الرجل
في غضون سته ايام لذا يجب ان يكون هناك
بعض النشاطات مع القيام بممارسه الجنس في
الوقت المناسب للاباضه العقاقير المنشطه
والتدخين والكحول ليس لها تاثير على
الخصوبه خرافه فالتدخين ضار بالبويضات لا
يجب عليك الا كليا عن الكحول اذا اردت
الحمل لكن التوسط هو الحل العقاقير
المنشطه ليست جيده لك او للبويضات او
الجنين اذا كنت تواجهين مشكله مع العقاقير
فاحصل على المساعده لانها لن تدعم الخصوبه
ولا حياتك